JUST GOT INFORMATION ON THAT.
WE JUST HEARD ABOUT IT BUT
WHATEVER IT IS, WE WILL LET YOU
KNOW.
BUT IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
OUR GOVERNMENT.
>> Reporter: [INAUDIBLE
QUESTION] >> President Trump:
BECAUSE A HOUSE IS A SET UP.
THE HOUSE IS A BUNCH OF TRUMP
HATERS.
THE SAME OLD STUFF.
THEY WANT OUR SITUATION TO BE
UNSUCCESSFUL WHICH MEANS THAT
DEATH, AND OUR SITUATION WILL BE
VERY SUCCESSFUL.
THE HOUSE HAS PUT ON AND
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE OF MAXINE
WATERS AND MALONEY AND THE SAME
PEOPLE AND IT’S SET UP.
BUT DR. FAUCI WILL BE TESTIFYING
IN FRONT OF THE SENATE AND HE
LOOKS FORWARD TO DOING THAT.
BUT THE HOUSE, I WILL TELL YOU,
AT THE HOUSE SHOULD BE ASHAMED
OF THEMSELVES AND FRANKLY THE
DEMOCRATS SHOULD BE ASHAMED
BECAUSE THEY DON’T WANT US TO
SUCCEED, THEY WANT US TO FAIL SO
THEY CAN WIN AN ELECTION WHICH
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO WIN.
BUT THINK OF IT.
THEY DO EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO
MAKE THINGS AS BAD AS POSSIBLE
AND RIGHT NOW THE STOCK MARKET
IS WAY UP, EVERYONE IS EXCITED
AND THEY ARE GOING BACK TO WORK.
THIS IS WHAT WE ARE DOING AND I
WILL TELL YOU THE WHOLE WORLD IS
EXCITED TO COME UP WATCHING US
BECAUSE WE ARE LEADING THE WORLD
WORLD.
WHAT HAPPENED SHOULD NEVER, EVER